[Music]  the winner of the voice is  sundae's head  I want to personally issue a challenge  to Universal Records this is season 11  of The Voice and I'm sitting here right  now next to a guy who has won over  America's hearts he's so popular it's  unbelievable and become a star out of  this show I hope and I and I give them  my word that I'll put my my work in and  I know he will this guy deserves to be a  star and there's no excuses anymore  we need to make the record and put the  work behind it that he deserves to have  this success that he deserves and that  has to start with Universal Records to  get involved and getting behind him  [Applause]  [Music]  you